just eight years ago exxon was the most
valuable company in the world boasting a
peak market cap of 446 billion dollars
but since then exxon has slowly slipped
down the list first they lost the number
one spot then they dropped out of the
top ten and now they've tumbled all the
way down to number 33 with a market cap
of 259 billion dollars that means that
exxon is officially over 10 times behind
the new market leader apple
to make things worse exxon has struggled
to regain profitability over the past
year and to top it all off exxon was
kicked out of the dow jones last year
the dow jones is a combination of the
top 30 american companies that meet a
set of guidelines and exxon had been
part of this list for 92 years
yet it looks like hitting a hundred
years in dao simply was not in the cards
for exon at first glance it's easy to
attribute this fall to the rise of evs
but evs only account for three percent
of global car sales so even though an eb
takeover is inevitable eevees aren't
really the ones eating intoxion's top
and bottom lines today
in fact exxon would likely be in a very
similar situation even if it wasn't
freebies so here's what happened to the
oil king that dominated the business
world for nearly a century
taking a look back the most obvious
factor behind exxon's fall is of course
crashing oil prices when your entire
business is based on oil you're
basically screwed if oil takes nose dive
and that's exactly what happened between
2014 and 2016.
within those two years oil prices
plummeted from 120 per barrel down to
just 40 per barrel this flash crash was
caught by a handful of factors most of
which exxon had no control over first of
all the us dollar was popping off
against the euro and given that
commodities are generally quoted in usd
a strengthening dollar meant flying
commodity prices
in the meantime china was actively
trying to do the exact opposite by
devaluing the yuan in 2015
you see it china likes to maintain a
weak currency on purpose and while that
might sound stupid there is reason
behind the madness when you have a weak
currency it's easier for foreigners to
forge your exports which increases
exports at the same time it also becomes
harder for citizens to afford imported
items which reduces overall imports
while this was a good thing for china
this was terrible for exxon given that
china is the world's largest oil
importer
all of a sudden exon had substantially
less revenue from americans and the
chinese and to make things worse the
middle eastern oil giants would screw
over exxon as well
given the reduced demand for oil it
would have been a smart move for opec to
decrease oil production
now a lot of you would argue that
decreasing production is an unethical
way to prop up prices but from their
side it would have been smart but they
actively decided not to reduce oil
production which led to a surplus and
oil which further drove down prices and
the nail in the coffin was the iran
nuclear deal which allowed iran to start
exporting oil once again
it's not clear how much of an impact
this additional supply actually had but
the threat itself was enough for
investors to flee oil all of these
factors combined led to exxon's revenue
crashing over 50 percent from 440
billion dollars down to 205 billion
dollars but falling oil prices was just
a taste of what was to come
usually with any investment the worst
case scenario is just losing everything
you put in
unless you're shorting a stock the worst
case scenario is just zero but with oil
prices things went beyond zero when all
prices literally went negative
no one really expected how quickly the
pandemic could shut down the entire
world and decrease all demand to nearly
zero so it's not surprising that
producers and refineries were left with
large amounts of excess oil once the
pandemic hit the problem though is that
you can't just throw the oil into some
reserves and try to sell it once demand
recovers
oil giants already had hundreds of
tankers carrying millions of barrels
worth of oil to their destinations but
once they reached their destination
customers no longer wanted the oil
so they literally had millions of
barrels of oil just floating around in
the ocean doing nothing and every day
these tankers were just sitting around
loads of money was being burned it was
just a matter of time until someone
broke and paid someone to simply take
away the oil and that's exactly what
happened on april 20th 2020. in just one
day crude oil futures fell 306 percent
from 18.27 cents to negative 37.63 cents
and just when you think that things
can't get any worse saudi arabia and
russia decide to have a price war common
sense would tell you that when oil
prices are plummeting and even going
negative it's a good time to heavily
reduce or even halt oil production
yet saudi arabia and russia decide to do
the exact opposite both of them knew
that the other was losing money and so
they tried to basically run each other
out of business
they did come to a truce eventually but
not before pumping up opec oil output to
30-year highs when prices were literally
negative
anyway exxon wasn't the leading voice
behind a 2014 oil crash the pandemic or
negative oil prices but they got
obliterated in the crossfire nothing
we've discussed so far is specific to
exxon and all oil companies were hurt by
these events but unlike exxon and shell
oil companies like chevron have almost
fully recovered
in fact chevron is only 10 to 15 away
from all-time highs and they never got
kicked from the dow jones so clearly a
lot of blame has to be placed on exxon
as well
probably the easiest loss exxon could
have avoided was making outsized bets on
the oil industry
even though eb's haven't made a big dent
in the overall oil industry yet it's
just a matter of time and investing
heavily into oil ventures is plain
stupid but that's exactly what exxon has
been doing over the past decade in 2009
they spent 41 billion dollars buying
extra energy in 2012 they spent 2.6
billion dollars buying celtic
exploration in 2017 they spent another
2.5 billion dollars requiring intra oil
and that same year they spent another
6.6 billion dollars to buy the best
family's permian assets
aside from making acquisitions left and
right exxon has also been investing
heavily into their own business
as recent as january 2020 the ceo of
exxon darren woods announced that exxon
will be investing 30 billion into
expiration projects in 2020 alone and
the plan was to spend 30 to 35 billion
dollars every year through 2025.
unfortunately for example all these poor
investments are only starting to bite
back after a decade for the longest time
exxon didn't want to admit that these
were bad investments they insisted that
these investments just needed time to
recover and they refused to value these
assets below what they paid for them but
recently exxon has been getting sued for
overvaluing their assets and the
misleading investors
exxon finally gave in at the end of 2020
and rolled off the 41 billion xto
investment as a 20 billion loss and this
right here is what really killed exxon
in 2020. even during the height of the
pandemic exxon was only losing half a
billion to one billion dollars per
quarter but after writing off this loss
in the last quarter of 2020 exxon posted
a 20 billion loss
and that marked the end of exxon's first
unprofitable year in 40 years
exxon isn't undeclared yet either there
are still multiple ongoing lawsuits
accusing exxon of overvaluing their
other assets
so last year's pain for write down may
just be the first of many
moving on to exxon's other big money
train we have their dividend payments
one of the defining characteristics of
exxon stock is their fallen history of
dividend payments
exxon has literally never missed a
different payment in their history
standard oil began paying a dividend in
1882 and exxon has kept up a tradition
ever since the breakup this means that
exxon didn't miss a payment through
world war one the great depression of
world war ii the inflation crisis 1973
oil crisis the dot-com bubble the
financial recession and of course the
pandemic this places exxon in an elite
group of stocks called dividend
aristocrats who not only never miss a
payment but continuously increase their
payments
it's not always super easy to pay a
dividend though especially a high
yielding dividend over the past few
years exxon has been forced to borrow
money to pay out their dividends and
while that's super irresponsible at this
point a lot of exxon's leadership would
rather file for bankruptcy than miss a
dividend payment and i don't blame them
if they miss a dividend payment not only
will they ruin a 140-year streak that's
virtually impossible to rebuild but they
would give up one of the only things
that's still going for exxon exxon may
be going bankrupt over the next decade
but one thing many investors are still
extremely confident in is that exxon
will pay dividends till the very end and
if exxon were to miss a payment right
now that would simply destroy investor
trust and drive down the stock price
even lower at least in the short term
with that being said though paying out a
massive dividend given the company's
situation is extremely irresponsible and
it's objectively holding back the
company
looking into the future it's not clear
where exxon is headed in terms of
financials exxon is nearly back to
pre-pandemic profit levels on a
quarterly basis but the thing to keep in
mind is that the pandemic wasn't what
hurt exxon the most it was actually
writing down that 20 billion investment
loss and given that exxon has plenty of
other such investments it's very
possible that they continue to increase
its losses over the next decade in the
meantime exxon refuses to embrace
renewable energy exxon is actually
currently being investigated for
spreading disinformation regarding
climate change and downplaying its
effects when questioned in court does
the euro darren woods of course deny
these allegations but whether exxon is
spreading this information or not their
stance on the future is crystal clear
darren woods has repeatedly reiterated
that climate change does not pose any
long-term threats to the oil industry in
my opinion this viewpoint is
fundamentally flawed as the transition
to renewable energy has little to do
with climate change now don't get me
wrong here switching to renewable energy
will help with combating climate change
but climate change is not what's pushing
the transition itself the primary
factors that will move the needle in my
opinion is electric options being more
convenient easier to maintain and most
importantly cheaper once these demands
are met companies and people will switch
to renewable options regardless of
whether they believe in climate change
or not now it's not like this change is
going to happen overnight and axon is
going to go bankrupt next year but the
longer exxon chooses to ignore this
trend the more likely it is that they'll
end up like texaco but that's just what
i think do you guys think exxon has a
future comment that down below
also drop a like if you're glad that the
era of all giants is coming to an end
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest a few video
ideas and consider subscribing and see
more questions logically answered but
until then i'm ari and i'll see you guys
on the next one
you